The second thing, of course, something
that Tucker Carlson said. Well, Tucker
Carlson says lots of things, but on
April 14th, he wrote the following,
quote, "The people in charge don't want
you to know this, but Muslims love
Jesus.
Islam reveres him as a major prophet and
messenger of the Lord, believes he
performed miracles, and states that he
will return to Earth to defeat the
Antichrist." Okay. Now, I'm addressing
this because, like I said, lots of you
contacted me about it, and you contacted
me about it because you know I've
addressed this many times before. This
is actually one of my pet peeves, as it
were, this Abrahamic business and trying
to conflate Islam with Christianity, for
example, and saying they share
commonality. So, yes, I would argue that
Muslims love Jesus, but I'm going to
clarify
because it doesn't mean what you think
it means.
This to idea keeps popping up, doesn't
it? Yes, according to Islamic teaching,
Muslims believe, and in keeping with the
Quran, that Jesus was born of a virgin
and that he was sinless. He was perfect.
And that he performed miracles and that
he's coming in the end times. So, yes,
of course, that sounds very impressive
if you're a Christian to find another
religion, which is often seen as a
competitor, a hostile antagonist, or
however you want to see it, whether you
want to see it realistically or not, and
then you find that, wow, as a Christian,
Christ is so central, and yet these
people are actually believe he was born
of a virgin, committed performed
miracles, was sinless, etc., etc. So,
that must not be so bad. Aha, but the
problem is how these things are actually
articulated and understood, and also the
omission, what's not said and what is
rejected. Okay? So, first of all, while
they do accept, let's what I would call
the nativity story, right, the Christmas
story, which is born of a virgin,
sinless, etc., they don't believe
actually the core doctrines of
Christianity, the much more important
and central doctrines of Christianity.
Not only do they not believe them, they
adamantly reject them. In fact, Muhammad
was sent specifically to redress these
claims about Jesus Christ that
Christians hold to. Namely that he was
the son of God, that he was actually
crucified
and died, that he was buried, and that
he was resurrected. Okay? That is, of
course, as we recently saw, the Easter
message. That is the gospel, the good
news. It's not so much that Jesus that,
you know, God was incarnate. That, of
course, is a major part of it. And as
we've seen, Muslims do accept that. But
they reject the whole point of why he
became incarnate, okay? And again, to
reiterate, they reject the central core
teachings of Christianity vocally. The
Quran says you are an infidel, a kafir,
which is the worst category in Islam for
a non-Muslim, cuz it basically means
open game on your blood. It's
articulated like that in Arabic. So,
you're a kafir, you can be killed
unless, of course, in the context of
you're a person of the book, but you're
still a kafir. You can pay tribute,
jizya, live as a subjugated dhimmi
according to Quran 9:29. But you are a
kafir, an infidel. There Quran says
infidels, or kuffar, kafirs plural, are
they who say Jesus is the son of Allah,
son of God, okay? And it also condemns
the concept of the Trinity.
All right? So, Islam is inherently
against what Christians, such as Tucker
Carlson, I assume, hold dearly to be
true about Jesus. And this leads to a
bigger issue about this whole
Abrahamism, as it's called, the idea
that Islam is actually a sister or
brother religion to Christianity because
it shares the same biblical figures,
going all the way back to Adam and Eve,
right? So, in the Quran, in Islamic
tradition, Adam and Eve, Moses, Noah,
everyone you can think about all the way
up until Jesus are mentioned and they're
all great prophets, of course. And they
all have their great roles, but they are
actually being appropriated by Muslims
beginning with Muhammad in order to
validate the message of Islam. Why?
Because if you're a 7th century Arab in
Arabia and the entire Middle East is
overwhelmed with Christianity and
everyone, including Jews, know who Moses
and Adam and Eve and and and Noah are,
okay? Those are the names associated
with faith and religion and God, okay?
And you're the 7th century Arab, well,
you better, of course, align yourself
with them and make them part of your
tradition, not come and say, "Oh,
they're all wrong and I'm right." But
the trick is he appropriated their
names, but then he changed who they
were, what they represented in a way to
validate his new message of Islam.
And so in the case of Jesus,
not only was he not crucified, not
killed, and therefore not resurrected,
and therefore not the son of God,
but he's actually very keen on
fulfilling Muhammad's worldview and
requests. So,
Jesus, when he comes back in the Islamic
tradition to Earth because he does
around Judgment Day and in that context,
he's an eschatological figure as well.
When he comes back, the things that
Jesus is going to be keen on doing is
breaking the cross, all the crosses,
killing all the pigs, and then
abrogating jizya.
As I alluded to, jizya is in Quran 9:29.
That's the central verse that calls for
un- unrestricted warfare on the people
of the book, which is Christians and
Jews, until they either convert or they
pay tribute, which is to say they pay
jizya, as it's called, and live as
second-class citizens, dhimmi's, et
cetera, or they fight to the death.
So, in coming back in the final days and
abrogating jizya, what Jesus is
ultimately saying is you now have to
either convert to Islam or fight to the
death, okay?
So, he's breaking the cross because he
doesn't because he's he's outraged that
Christians for a couple of millennia or
whenever how how many years it will be
when he comes back in the Islamic
rendering, he's upset, so he's breaking
the cross as an indication that he was
never crucified, you silly Christians.
And he's going to kill all the pigs
because, you know, Christians are eating
pigs and it's not really Muslims don't.
It's not very kosher in that sense. And
he's finally going to abrogate jizya,
which means now you either become Muslim
or die. Well, you know what that's like
actually? So, so the Jesus that the
Muslims love, as Tucker Carlson said,
and they do, he's really Well, first of
all, he's not Jesus. His name is Isa.
And what he is is really a doppelganger.
You know, he's the evil twin of the real
Jesus. He's much more like an ISIS
figure, isn't he?
ISIS is very fond of quoting the phrase
which traces back to early Islamic
history, break the cross. They they say
it all the time and they engage in it.
Not just ISIS, radical Muslims, as it
were. Um they break the cross because
it's so provocative, it's anathema to
Islam, the idea of the crucifix. There's
a Hadith where Muhammad supposedly, if
he entered anywhere and even saw some
makeshift symbol that looked like a
cross, would just go crazy and break it.
Hence why the phrase break the cross,
and that's why Muslims, including ISIS
and others, do it. Okay? So, there it is
about the Jesus and what Tucker Carlson
said. All right? Yeah, Muslims love Isa,
who's more of an ISIS figure, who's
going to come, break all the crosses
because Christianity is wrong, and he's
going to make sure that Christians can
no longer even pay to be
second-class dhimmi's, they have to
convert or die. All right? So, there's
that cuz this is really an an
interesting topic. If you really want to
understand the concept, and I've said
this before, I've written a lot about
this, this idea of appropriation and
religions and and so forth being close
to each other, sister religions. The
irony is when you find two religions
that have some sort of commonality and
ostensibly seem to be close,
or in this case use the same figures and
the same names, the more prone they are
actually to hate each other as opposed
to building bridges and being friends.
Now, why is that? Use your reason and
think about it. If there's two religions
that have absolutely nothing to do with
each other, no historical intersection.
Okay? Let's say, I don't know, Hinduism
and Christianity. Very different
religions, obviously. One's
polytheistic, one's monotheistic,
despite what Muslims say.
And, um, you know, historically they
don't intersect. I don't believe
anything in the Hindus' scriptures or
tradition even mention or acknowledge or
know about Jesus. And, of course, in in
the Christian tradition in the Bible,
there's nothing really about Hindus.
Okay? So, on the one hand, they have
nothing to do with each other. Does that
by nature mean now, you know, going back
to the idea that they're going to be
especially hostile? Well, I suppose
every religion is fundamentally
generically hostile to the other because
each one is supposedly claiming a truth.
And if you're going to claim a different
truth, then, yeah, there's obviously an
obstacle. But, it's very generic and
this would exist between every religion.
So, Christianity, Islam, Hinduism,
Judaism, all these religions would have
the same idea, which is, um, essentially
we have a we have a a truth, you
obviously don't accept it, you
contradict it to one degree or the
other, and therefore we're not aligned.
Okay? That, I think, is a generic. But,
now the idea is, uh, that if there is,
for example, the Islam the Islam case,
you have a religion which, okay,
obviously it rejects what I talked about
about Christ and the central core
teachings, but it accepts a lot of the
other things. So, therefore, they should
be kind of close. No, okay? And I'm
going to give you an analogy to
understand what this how this goes. I've
given it before, which is basically
imagine you you have a grandfather and
he's dead now, and you knew him and you
were very fond of him and you know, you
have great recollections of him,
spending time with him, you looked up to
him, etc., etc. And then all of a sudden
some stranger you never met comes up to
you and says, "Hey, that was my
grandfather, too." Okay, now right
there, on the surface, that seems like a
good thing. Wow, a new commonality is
going to be built, right? This person
and and me, we have the same
grandfather. We're going to sit around
and you know,
reminisce about how great he was. I'm
going to learn from him different
things, he's going to learn from me.
But then this fellow tells you that and
everything you know about your
grandfather is completely wrong. All the
stuff you think he said and did, not
true. It's actually what I'm going to
tell you. And then he starts to tell you
things about your grandfather that you
never expected, you never heard, you
never associated with him. Disturbing
things even. All right? So, in the
context of what we're talking about,
Jesus. So,
at the sake of sounding sacrilegious or
blasphemous, imagine Jesus is your
grandfather and you love him, okay? And
you believe in you believe he taught
what he taught in the Christian
teaching. And then this fellow comes and
says, "Ah, he's my grandfather, too, but
he taught that he's going to break the
cross and he's going to kill the pigs
and he's going to and he never, you
know, he doesn't he never told you that
he was or it was never said that he was
crucified and resurrected, etc."
Now, how on earth is that going to build
a bridge between you and this person?
Think about it. So, the whole point is
the argument is very superficial. It
just looks at the fact that oh, we share
the same names and the same people and
therefore, oh, we're natural allies.
But the fact is, it's because you share
the same names, but at the same time,
you see these names and personages in a
completely different way. They mean
something different. Well, that actually
is now an obstacle. That's not a a cause
of friendship. That's a greater obstacle
than if it was the person who doesn't
say I know your grandfather, which is to
say than if it was a Hindu or a Buddhist
or someone of another religion that
doesn't have anything to do with Jesus
in this case. Do you see what I'm
saying? So, the idea that we often hear
that oh, these are cousin religions and
oh, wow, we have a natural bridge to
build, etc. etc. It's It's it the exact
opposite. The closer religions are, the
more prone they are to actually hate and
war with each other. Look at Catholicism
and Protestantism. To the outside world,
they're both Christians. And by and
large, they are both Christians, right?
They both believe in the core tenets
about Jesus Christ. They both agree that
he was
you know, like Muslims, that he was born
of a virgin, etc. etc. Performed
miracles, that he was the son of God,
that he was crucified, that he was
resurrected, and is coming to judge,
okay? So, you would think wow,
Protestants and Catholics should be the
absolute best of friends. Historically,
well, they killed each other left and
right. They weren't killing Hindus.
All right? But they were killing each
other because again, the closer you get,
the more prone for violence and or
actual hostility to exist between the
two groups. So, I think that's a final
important point to make in regards to
Mr. Carlson's claims. And here it is,
let me read it again. So, the people in
charge don't want you to know this, but
Muslims love Jesus.
Islam reveres him as a major prophet and
messenger of the Lord. No, that's true.
Believes he performed miracles, true.
And states that he will return to Earth
to defeat the Antichrist. True. Okay?
But as we just saw, the whole problem is
that what Jesus is to Muslims is not
what Christians say he is to Muslims.
Muslims love Isa. They don't love Jesus.
And Isa is a counterfeit Jesus Christ
who teaches the opposite things. That's
the truth,
Mr. Carlson. Bring back the
fire. Bring back the
fire and the
righteousness.